okay Oh a major Donald Trump campaign
promise was actually something that is a
long-standing Democratic pledge which is
let Medicare negotiate bulk discounts
when it comes to the prices it pays for
prescription drugs well that's not gonna
happen
another bamboozling by Donald Trump
yesterday Donald Trump met with
pharmaceutical industry lobbyists and
executives and all of a sudden Trump
comes out of that meeting and the plan
to negotiate drug prices down has
disappeared what's the new plan lower
taxes and get rid of regulations shocked
I am shocked that once again Trump's
plan has changed from something that
sounded vaguely good for consumers to
the standard crony capitalists
trickle-down nonsense that helps big
corporations in their executives most
countries that have national health care
and by that I mean most countries at our
level of development other than the
United States do this right they
negotiate better deals on drug place
prices to include them nationally in
their health care justice system and
manufacturing pills is so cheap that
it's usually still very profitable for
big pharma we don't have a national
healthcare system but we do have
Medicare for seniors and it's a really
big country so negotiating makes sense
however there's a 2003 law written by
congressional Republicans signed on to
by our old buddy George W Bush and it
prohibits the federal government from
using that negotiating power and as
recently as January 11th Trump was ready
to revisit the policy and get the
negotiation going here's what Donald
Trump said during a press conference on
January 11th Pharma has a lot of lobbies
a lot of lobbyists and a lot of power
and there's very little bidding on drugs
we're the largest buyer of drugs in the
world and yet we don't bid properly
agreed completely so let's negotiate
however Donald Trump met yesterday with
pharma lobbyists and pharma executives
and he comes out of the meeting and
what's the new policy for Trump take a
look at this quote I'll oppose anything
that makes it harder for smaller younger
companies to take the risk of
bringing their product to a vibrantly
competitive market that includes
price-fixing by the biggest dog in the
market Medicare before it was
negotiating for Medicare
now it's price-fixing by Medicare which
is what's happening Trump went on to say
but we can increase competition and
bidding wars big time so what I want we
have to get lower prices we have to get
even better innovation and I want you to
move your companies back into the United
States and I want you to manufacture in
the United States we're going to be
lowering taxes we're going to be getting
rid of regulations that are unnecessary
key points here price fixing by Medicare
in other words Medicare working to keep
prices low
he used to before that via negotiation
now he's against it and of course the
new solution is lower taxes and get rid
of regulations which of course is a way
for what for Big Pharma to increase
their profit margin with absolutely no
requirement to pass on the savings to
consumers does anybody get what's going
on here pat on most of the big public
policy issues of the day Trump started
out with seemingly populist rhetoric but
he's coming back to the standard
establishment Republican trickle-down
nonsense every single time yeah it's
really too bad he campaigned as a
populist and you see more and more now
he's taking on the positions of more
establishment Republicans the obvious
that Reince Priebus is in his ear oh
yeah he also promised that he wasn't
going to touch Medicare he wasn't going
to touch Social Security we have to keep
them through that it's another way and
another example of Trump changing his
mind to whatever someone told him five
minutes ago in this case in the literal
sense he went in and met with big pharma
lobbyists and executives and five
minutes later he comes out he has a
totally new position on negotiating drug
prices make America great again how does
this help the average person how does
this help a lower income a lower middle
class person a middle class person to
afford medications it doesn't it doesn't
discuss this with us on Reddit david
pakman.com slash re d di t today's
episode is made possible in part by
menswear line endowed Chino I often had
a problem buying off-the-rack suits and
blazers because
I sort of have an oddly shaped body I
guess is the point I'm getting at I
would start with a 38 but that was just
too big I would try the 38 short which
fit a little better but because of my
absurdly long arms which many people
often point out to me I then had a
problem because the arm length the
sleeve length was too short not a
problem when I went to the Boston Indo
Chino showroom and worked with Chris
there who walked me through selecting
everything from the fabric to the button
style to the lapels and the lining and
everything of my suit and four weeks
later I had a custom suit specifically
made for me which was really really
great if you can't get to one of Indo
chinos 9 North American showrooms and
work with somebody like I worked with
Chris at the Boston showroom you can go
to the endo chino website and it will
explain to you how to take all the body
measurements that are necessary to get a
great fitting custom suit you plug them
in make your selections and four weeks
later you've got a custom suit right
there ready to wear this week David
Pakman show viewers and listeners can
get any premium Indo Chino suit for 389
at Indo Chino comm but you must enter
the coupon code Pakman at checkout
that's PA que ma n 50% off the regular
price for a may to measure premium suit
shipping is free Indo Chino comm promo
code Pakman any premium suit 389 plus
free shipping I love my Indo Chino suit
check it out